do you do your own stunts on uh Superman
and Lois I used to I don't want any more
it's not something you get older and you
decide when I dislocated it which was a
few months ago on Superman and Lois you
dislocated your shoulder again Superman
and Lois what were you doing when you're
on wires no I was freezing cold
Vancouver I'm doing this Dope fight
sequence with Superman right and
um it was freezing I wasn't warm enough
I'd been training for weeks I blocked a
punch he kind of blocked it hard and it
just went like
you felt it
immense pain I have to go to emergency
that day on the set you had to go to the
emergency room yeah because they
wouldn't put it back in did they try to
put it back in no because you know if a
nerve gets caught were you crying I was
bawling my uh wait oh this is the best
story ever I he told the story I don't
think so all right move your mic up so
it could hear you a little bit it was it
was out of socket for um two hours
because we're in the middle of you shot
in Vancouver right oh yeah Smallville
was in Vancouver okay so we're in Delta
a farm in Delta and bumper in yes sorry
and uh it take we would take more time
for the ambulance to get there than for
them to drive me to the hospital so I'm
going across like bumpy Farm terrain
completely out of socket like can barely
breathe every step is like excuse me I'm
in my super suit and I get to the
hospital super suit yeah because it was
the alternate universe
they
couldn't like are you kidding I couldn't
move so I get to emergency and I'm like
CR I'm hysterical at this point I'm
begging them for drugs the doctor comes
I'm like please just put it back in
socket and they give me some morphine
they gave me like a relaxant they had to
cut the costume the costumer was with me
they had to cut the costume off and the
nurse you know she sees it I'm in this
like full-on super suit and I'm so high
at this point she's like so who are you
who are you fighting dear I was like I
was looking around I was like Superman
oh oh effed up on drugs Morphine at this
time and she says here you fight and
you're just you just look at it and say
Superman she was like
okay
oh my God the whole thing was so awful
anyways that's the long-winded answer so
no I do not do my stunts anymore that's
it I'm done I have this most amazing
stunt double let her do what she does
what how long before you were fixed
again did they did they put it in socket
back in the socket right oh yeah while
you were drugged up yeah and you didn't
feel it no it was instant relief and
then I was back at work the next day are
you serious I'm not did you stay the
night in the hotel in the hospital no I
was out like as soon as they popped it
back in did all the paperwork I was out
did Tyler who plays Superman was he just
like oh I'm so sorry no he was like I
mean he had nothing to apologize for but
he just knew he when it happened he was
like oh
and he just knew and and he was like
being very protective because you know
what's the what's is there anything
worse than getting hurt on set
oh God that's what happens when you're
50. I'm not kidding I've had I've had
injuries where I'm just like oh God oh
God Mike I can't I get my back I just
threw my back out oh my God you yeah
Brian have you ever been injured during
sex not like that no I have